for a lone grasshopper this tree branch
is fraught with danger predators are
everywhere and one is especially
formidable the preying mantis
he's armed and dangerous five eyes up to
six inches long and a head that can turn
180 degrees but his chief weapon is
camouflage the grasshopper doesn't stand
a chance
mantises can make short work of a long
list of insects moths
crickets flies and even other mantises
yes even a mantises own mate is
sometimes on the menu the big predatory
bug is related to both termites and
cockroaches though no cockroach can
blend in this well but the Mantis isn't
the only predator lurking in the
branches
if he doesn't watch out a chameleon
might make him its lunch